c'est un mec qui se fait exploser en
mobylette sur une route la nuit en
février 2008 et vous le ramassez et un
jour il revient vous voir sur une chaise
roulante c'est très perturbant c'est
très traumatisant parce qu'on y pense
tout le temps
bonsoir on commence avec vous dans
Pascal Obispo quand les gens ont vu que
vous n'étiez plus dans le jury de The
Voice certains se sont dit oh [ __ ] il
va faire un album
c'est fait la pochette est top elle est
très très rock on a un peu l'impression
que vous essayez d'attraper directement
dans la bouche une cacahuète quand vous
a quand vous avez fait juste bourré par
le même visible
alors ensuite donc il y aura une tournée
dans toute la France à partir du 15
janvier dont deux dates donc le 12 et le
13 février une tournée basée sous le
signe du grattage d'oreilles compliquées
ouais mais tu sais quand on est amoureux
de tatouage et surtout ceux de Tintin
[Musique]
pardon est tant pis pour la polémique
mais j'embrasse Milo
tu vas trop loin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Pascal Obispo roman ce soir
alors Pascal on va parler de votre album
vous allez ensuite nous faire un morceau
live merci mais avant ça je voudrais
savoir quelles leçons vous tirez de
votre saison chez The Voice parce que il
y a un an vous n'étiez pas très chaud
magnétos Serge
vas-y dans The Voice vous adorez l'idée
des auditions à l'aveugle mais vous
dites que vous ne pourriez pas faire
partie du jury vous trouvez ça trop
cruel en
plus ouais mais quand tu sais que
la passion
David attention
depuis tout petit quand tu es passionné
de musique c'est super dur à quelqu'un
qui aime profondément la musique et qui
aime chanter qui fait ça depuis des
années de lui dire ben non mon gars je
choisis l'autre à côté ça c'est pas un
truc qui me qui me branche et voilà
donc ça a été ça a été masculin ça a été
ma plus grande difficulté effectivement
moi j'y suis allé parce que c'était un
programme bienveillant c'est un bon
j'aime la bienveillance
comme Patrick Sébastien exactement bien
alors on va passer à l'album maintenant
le titre alors fini les conneries style
Captain Samurai flowers
de la Fnac c'est plus facile quand le
Macari vous avez 10 d'Obispo ben oui
Obispo on l'a il est là c'est un titre
qu'on appelle éponyme éponyme ça fait
classe de dire éponymes
comment ça va comme
ça c'est le titre
alors c'est difficile ça commence je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que c'est
un album qui est tellement éclectique
éclectique
c'était difficile de trouver un titre
qui chapote le tout c'est vrai ou pas
parce que c'est un même très personnel
où j'ai mis beaucoup d'influence tous
les niveaux quoi c'est à dire de mes
références aussi bien musicales que
littéraire que que géographique que
personnel alors l'esprit de l'album
c'est un retour aux sources en fait dans
le règne des années 80 l'époque de
Philippe Pascal de marquisard de Marc
Seberg et vous avez une phrase qui est
assez juste finalement la musique qui
nous reste toute notre vie c'est celle
de notre adolescence et la musique de
votre adolescence était police c'était
cure c'était Joy Division et c'était
marqué de ça évidemment je pense qu'on
en est tout seul
je ne fais que commencer presque en fait
je reviens
à mes racines j'avais envie de retrouver
la musique qui m'a fait grandir et qui
m'a construit et celle qui m'a construit
c'est celle enfin en partie celle que tu
as cité celle que j'ai appris dans des
groupes de rock à Rennes voilà bon ça
fait pas de mon album un album rock mais
ça fait ça fait de cet album un album
très pop très énergique un petit peu
comme
plus j'ai écrit beaucoup de choses dans
la vie quasiment tous les textes j'ai
raconté regardez l'époque de Rennes
d'accord si tu veux
[Musique]
ailleurs
c'est toujours toi
à quoi
sert de partir
[Musique]
son visage sur les murs des souvenirs
qui durent
ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on était toujours habillé en noir et
comme je suis passé pour la première
fois à la télé j'avais pris un costume
blanc
qu'est-ce que vous vous dites là
je me dis enfin ça me donne envie de
chanter cet album parce que je pense
qu'à l'époque je ne savais absolument
pas chanter et en 25 ans j'ai un peu
appris donc ça me donne envie de
reprendre les bandes et de refaire un
bon disque avec ce disque de reposer une
voix est-ce que est-ce que vous avez
regretté finalement ensuite d'être
devenu un chanteur de variété en fait
quand j'ai commencé la musique donc j'ai
commencé avec des groupes de rock mais
quand je suis arrivé à Paris la musique
que je proposais n'intéressait personne
avec ma voix grave et donc il a fallu
que que je trouve un voilà une idée mon
idée ça a été de de chanter en voix de
tête voilà et donc et après on connaît
l'histoire même
sentiment en fait d'avoir vendu votre
âme au diable non mais on peut on peut
parler de d'une forme d'adaptation à
l'époque j'imagine que les maisons me
disent vous poussez vers la variété
parce que vous êtes libéré tel succès
tout le monde une fois que ça a commencé
ah oui je pouvais pas c'était terminé
vous avez fait des chansons quand même
inoubliables il y en a
[Musique]
je l'ai dit
il est pêche toi on vit on meurt une
fois
et on a le temps de rien
[Musique]
c'est génial c'est un grand mélodie
un immense il y a très peu de grands
mélodies il y a Julien Clerc je parle
toujours des paroliers de Julien
clercs
superbe-moi siffle-moi une chanson
mais est-ce que sérieusement voilà
maintenant vous êtes à l'âge mur est-ce
que finalement vous dites pas j'aurais
mieux fait de rester sur mon truc de
Rennes et faire téléphone faire non
parce que je pense que d'abord au
téléphone c'est pas marqué de ça d'arrêt
mais non le truc c'est que si j'avais
pas si j'avais continué à faire du rock
je pense que j'aurais peut-être toujours
été un artiste inconnu incompris et
frustré je passe réalise dans la musique
moi la chance que j'ai eu justement ça
vous êtes très
artistes mais c'est vrai que
l'adolescent si tu demandes à
l'adolescent que je suis encore c'est
vrai que le le rêve que j'avais c'était
c'était d'un d'être dans un groupe de
rock mais pasteur même guitariste et de
faire et d'être alors on va regarder
maintenant chante la rue et ensuite vous
nous ferez rien ne dure d'accord ok
magnétos Serge
[Musique]
use allez chante
les pensées qui te hante les idées
auxquelles tu tiens chante as-tu
les rendre sourds ils sont depuis
longtemps bravo très bien
et voilà alors il y a de nombreuses
featurings donc dans votre album il y a
Isabelle Adjani en fait c'est une
chanson que vous aviez fait pour un
album d'Isabelle qu'on a jamais fini
un extrait de cet album et c'est un
magnifique absolument avec Sundo
Calogero Philippe Pascal évidemment René
markinson Christophe et il y a une
chanson qui s'appelle on n'est pas seul
sur terre et c'est une histoire c'est
extraordinaire c'est un mec qui se fait
exploser en mobylette sur une route la
nuit en février 2008 et vous le ramassez
et un jour il revient vous voir sur une
chaise roulante oui mais j'ai vu un
accident et puis j'ai ramassé le gars
qui était qui était par terre donc
et c'était un peu s'il était déchiqueté
parce qu'il avait des membres aussi qui
étaient séparés de son corps donc voilà
et c'est
très perturbant c'est très traumatisant
parce qu'on y pense tout le temps et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on
aujourd'hui j'avais besoin d'en faire
une chanson et d'en parler et si j'ai
fait cette chanson c'est parce que c'est
vrai un an après je l'ai retrouvé on a
fait on a sympathisé il a donc un bras
en moins et une jambe en moins et c'est
un cette chanson qui s'appelle honnête
pas celle sur la terre parce que il
s'est fait défoncer par un par un
connard qui est en plus ne s'est pas
arrêté on est pas seul parce que c'est
vrai que j'étais là par hasard et on est
pas seul parce que le Nicolas comment il
s'appelle Nicolas et quelqu'un
d'extrêmement
touchant et bienveillant et je trouve
que c'est un être extraordinaire comme
le chantait les innocents cet homme
extraordinaire dont on ne parle jamais
qui passe sa vie à aider les à aider à
aider les autres à se battre pour les
autres alors que finalement il a il a
beaucoup tout faire et j'avais envie de
faire cette chanson pour lui parce que
c'est c'est vraiment un mec incroyable
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant c'est l'heure du live rien
ne dure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien ne dure
9 mois plus rien n'est sûr
[Musique]
acné premier baiser
combien de temps d'amour à partager
[Musique]
passion des secrets
le reste des regrets
c'est comme ça on s'y fait
on a pas le temps freiner
que la Porsche de James
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans cette course
[Musique]
avant la vie d'après
pour nous simplement
de changer sous le ciel
ou alors il faudrait pouvoir créer un
carnet sur la Porsche de James
[Musique]
les chanteurs leurs blessures
quand tu contre moi
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu